find the greatest common factor of these
monomials now the greatest common factor
of anything is the largest factor that's
divisible into both if we're talking
about just pure numbers into both
numbers or in this case into both
monomials now we have to be a little bit
careful when we talk about greatest in
the context of algebraic expressions
like this because its greatest from the
point of view that it includes the most
factors of each of these each of these
monomials it's not necessarily the
greatest possible number because maybe
some of these variables could take on
negative values maybe they're taking on
values less than one so if you square it
is actually going to become a smaller
number but I think without getting too
much into the weeds there I think if we
just kind of run through the process of
it you'll understand it a little bit
better so to find the greatest common
factor let's just essentially break down
each of these numbers into what we could
call their prime factorization but it's
kind of a combination of the prime
factorization of the numeric parts of
the number plus essentially the
factorization of the variable parts so
if we wanted to write ten we could say
or we if we were to write ten CD squared
we can rewrite that as the product of
the prime factors of ten the prime
factorization of ten is just two times
five those are both prime numbers so ten
can be broken down as two times five see
can only be broken down by C we don't
know anything else that C can be broken
into so C so two times five times C but
then the d squared can be rewritten as D
times D D times D this is what I mean by
writing this monomial essentially as the
product of its constituents for the
numeric part of it it's the constituents
are the prime factors and for the rest
of it is we're just kind of expanding
out the exponents now let's do that for
25 C to the third d squared so 25 right
here that's 5 times 5 so this is equal
to 5 times 5 and then C to the third
that's times C times C times C and then
d squared times D squared d squared is
times D
is d so what's their greatest common
factor in this context well they both
have at least one v they both have at
least one v then they both have at least
one C over here so let's just take up
one of the C's right over there and then
they both have two DS they both have two
DS so the greatest common factor in this
context the greatest common factor of
these two monomials is going to be the
factors that they have in common so it's
going to be equal to this five times we
only have one C in common times and we
have two DS in comments times D times D
so this is equal to five c d squared and
so five d squared we can kind of view it
as the greatest but I'll put that in
quotes where you know depending on
whether C is negative or positive and D
is a greater than or less than zero but
this is the greatest common factor of
these two monomials it's divisible into
both of them and it uses the most
factors possible